if you've known John for a long time
what makes that guy
interesting uh special and and good what
have you learned about Jiu Jitsu in life
from John Donahue he's super smart
I mean eccentric and he leaves
through Jiu Jitsu he's 24 7 thinking
better ways to teach how to make his
competitors better
and that is a coach when you have that
dedication as a coach that it makes the
most difference of your athletes like
which other big team you have that coach
with that motivation
all the other
schools is either someone that competes
that pushed the training like on drug
overall it's no he's one of the
competitors so he brings the hype in
everyone else but he doesn't have the
time he doesn't spend the time working
individually I mean I'm sure he does but
he's limited because he's also a
competitor
and you know looking
most of the other big schools like
you don't have that nowaday all the
leaders the the main coaches for The
Other big schools they have other things
other things in their lives they could
not don't fully dedicate it to the
athletes John does
you know look at the interview he spends
hours and hours a day studying how can
away the system you know to make his
athletes better
look at the results